(cheery music)
- [Kelly Clarkson] All
right, now performing
"Dem Time Deh",
featuring Manuel Turizo,
give it up for Sean Paul, everybody!
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
♪ It's the live and living scorcha ♪
♪ Along side Kelly Clarkson ♪
♪ The God daughter ♪
♪ Ayo Manuel chat to 'em ♪
(Manuel sings in foreign language)
♪ Real Way ♪
♪ (Manuel sings in foreign language) ♪
(Sean Paul sings in foreign language)
♪ All right then ♪
♪ Officially official keep on slaying ♪
♪ Special to me like blood in my veins ♪
♪ You're about to be
the number one being ♪
♪ In my world baby girl ♪
♪ You know what I'm saying ♪
♪ Attached to me like a ball and chain ♪
♪ Move that body that's
stuck in my brain ♪
♪ Love the energy the way that I see ♪
♪ Baby girl me walk in
the fire and flame ♪
♪ Sexy mamita the day I met you ♪
♪ My life got sweeter I can't complain ♪
♪ You make my head feel
high like a plane ♪
♪ Start up the engine ♪
♪ Fire and flame ♪
(upbeat music continues)
(Manuel sings in foreign language)
(Sean Paul sings in foreign language)
♪ Biri bam bam bam yo ♪
♪ Baby girl I love how you do it ♪
♪ Love seeing you move
your body to the beat ♪
(Sean Paul sings in foreign language)
♪ Keep doing it ♪
♪ Baby girl just bubble and thing ♪
♪ Move that body girl shake for the king ♪
♪ Cause you done know
he loves how you swing ♪
♪ That will make him ♪
♪ Invest in the ring ♪
(upbeat music continues)
(Manuel sings in foreign language)
(Sean Paul sings in foreign language)
♪ Ay yo ♪
♪ It's the live and living scorcha ♪
♪ You know it's Kelly Clarkson Show ♪
♪ Ya man take off yourself and let go ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Kelly Clarkson] One more time y'all,
let's hear it for Sean
Paul and Manuel Turizo!
(audience roars)
Their single "Dem Time Deh" is available
for download now.
Y'all got to go get it.
We'll be right back with
(audience drowns out speaker)